مع بدايه السباق الرمضاني واجهت بعض
الاعمال الدراميه المصريه انتقادات تصل حد
الدعاوى القضائيه وذلك بسبب ما تتضمنوا من
مشاهد عنف او اساءه للمراه وايضا تعاطي
المخدرات وصولا الى التدخين منظمات عده
كالمجلس الاعلى لتنظيم الاعلام بمصر
والمجلس القومي للمراه يرصد هذه المشاهد
ويضعها في اطار التجاوزات الى مدى تؤثر
هذه التقارير اذا على نجاح العمل الدرامي
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد انضم الينا من القاهره
ضيفنا الدائم في مساء العربيه الناقد
الفني طارق الشناوي سيد طارق اهلا بك مساء
الخير مساء الخير من جديد مساء الفل اهلا
بك طيب لنتحدث عن الاعمال التي تعتبرها من
وجهه نظرك استخدمت فيها مشاهد العنف
والاجرام والمخدرات لكن من دون هدف
بصي الامر اصله المجالس المتعدده اللي
بترصد النوع ده من مثلا التدخين سواء كان
مخدرات او مجرد التدخين العنف
الكلمات اللي ممكن تبقى موجوده في عمل
درامي حاليا في عدد كبير من الاعمال لكن
هل طريقه الرصد نفسها طريقه صحيحه وصحيه
انا فاكر من حوالي سبع سنين كان في مسلسل
اسمه تحت السيطره كان بيتناول موضوع
التعاطي بانواعه فبدات منظمات
الطبيه تقدم تقارير وقفوا هذا المسلسل
لانه يساهم في زياده جرعات التعاطي وكثافه
التعاطي في العالم العربي كله ثم بعد كده
نفس المؤسسات دي هقولها او الهيئات دي
عملت ندوات وتكريمات لصناعه العمل لانه ما
كانش ممكن تواجه التعاطي من غير ما تقدم
تعاطي بس هو سؤال كيف يقدم هل بغرض
الترويج او انك بتقدم للناس بتقول كذا لو
تذكر انه مع بدايه المجلس الاعلى للاعلام
رصده قال لك اللي هيلاقي لفظ قبيح او خارج
هياخد 100,000 جنيه فطبعا دي كانت كارثه
لانه الناس سابت شغلها وقعدت تدور على
كلمه ما فيش عمل فني
تبصي على كلمه او مشهد لا عليه ككل في
سياقه ككل وبعد كده تقول هل هنا في حتميه
ولا كان في ترويج هو ده يبقى الموضوع لكن
اللي بيحصل الرصد الرقمي
بدنا نضبط الموضوع كيف بدنا نناقش قضيه
مخدرات او عنف ضد المراه مثلا اذا لم يتم
تصوير مثل هذه المشاهد
[موسيقى]
ما هو عشان كده الجهاد ديت غالبا بتبقى
الرصد عندها بالورقه والقلم والرقم فما
بتطلعش النتائج صحيحه بتطلع مجرد يقول لك
كان هنا كان في مشهد اقتصاب هنا كان في
عنف على المراه ما هو انت عشان تواجه
العنف الموجه للمراه يجب علي انا كمتلقي
الاقي في عنف موجه للمراه فابتدي اتعاطف
مع المراه لكن يعني ازاي ندافع عن المراه
بدون ما نقدم مشاهد العنف ضدها وبعدين
الحاجه التانيه هل تقديم امراه منحرفه ده
ضد المراه ولا الدراما المفروض انها
قماشتها بتسعى الجميع فبرده في الهي
مفاهيم خاطئه شديده لكن مثلا مؤكده مثلا
جعفر العمده مساحه العنف فيه وضرب نار
كنموذج يعني مساحه العنف فيهم زياده كان
ممكن تقلصهم لكن مش معنى كده الغائهم
يعني المشاهد العنيفه والضربه وموجوده
فعلا بكثافه كان ممكن الغيها لكن الغاء
جزء منها لكن الغائها تماما او محاكمه
العمل الفني فقط من هذا
المعيار انا بشوفها خاطئه جدا يعني
هتخلينا نصف عمل انه عظيم لمجرد ان
ابطالهوش سيجاره مثلا
على الرغم من صدور هذه التقارير السنويه
هذا العام تكتسح دراما الشعبيه مسلسلات
رمضان تكثر فيها هذه المشاهد مشاهد العنف
والمخدرات كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
[موسيقى]
هي طبعا في النهايه الامر
عند المبدع نفسه وعندي نواياه هل هو فعلا
عايز يروج يعني لو انت عايز تروج لتعاطي
الحشيش مثلا
هل تعتبر ان الكيت كات بيروج للحشيش برغم
انه محمود عبد العزيز اللي هو الشيخ حسني
عامل دور جميل جدا وبيتعاطى على طول
مخدرات كويس لا كان بيواجه ده فبالتالي
بيزل الحكم من خلال المعالجه وليس عدد
المرات التي تم فيها التعاطي او الضرب او
القنص او او لان الاحكام اللي من هذا
النوع هي مقتل الدراما لو انت عايز تقتل
الدراما في اي مجتمع امسك ورقه وقلم وقول
انا هقيم العمل الفني بعدد مرات العنف عدد
مرات التعاطي عدد مرات الخيانه الكلمات
ممكن تجتزع من سياقها فتقول الكلمه دي
كلمه قبيحه لكن انت من منطقه ما هو فاتن
حمامه في الخيط الرفيع قالت ابن الكلب في
الحوار لكن لكن هل دي كلمه قبيحه ولا كانت
لها منطق درامي سقف في العمل الفني وهكذا
فانا ضد ضد الاصطياد اللي احيانا بيبقى
بياثر سلبا على الدراما
دراما بغض النظر يعني خليني بس انا هيك
اعطيك تعليق تعقيب على كلامك دائما
بنتقدوا الاعمال الدراميه والافلام
والمسلسلات اللي فيها سب وفيها الشتائم
وكاننا نعيش في مدن فاضله ما الواحد ما كل
كلامه حلو ومعسول
انا دايما اقول انه احنا لا نعيش في حجرات
معقمه احنا بنعيش في الشارع مش في مش في
حجره معقمه الشارع فيه جراثيم
والحياه ايضا فيها جراثيم كويس وبالتالي
الدراما لازم يبقى فيها كل حاجه لكن مش
معنى كده ان احنا نروج للجراثيم او
للموبقات ولكن تقدم فمع الاسف في اصوات
بين الحين والاخر بتطالب بتعقيم الدراما
وده اسوا شيء ممكن يواجه العربيه كلها
الاصوات دي التي تطالب بتهذيب واصلاح
وتاديب اي عمل درامي احنا بنشكرك جزيل
الشكر من القاهره ضيفنا دائما في مسائل
العربيه الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات